shame
[Music]
uh what a lead well for this episode I'm
joined by a rugby league Legend today's
guest he's been a New Zealand Warrior a
pen with Panther a West tiger while also
playing 11 games for the kiwis he has
since moved to the UK where he's played
for Salford and now running around for
the Featherstone Rovers and on top of
all that he's a qualified commercial
pilot and even a rap artist and if all
that's not enough he also has one of the
craziest stories in sport after finding
out his manager had stolen four hundred
thousand dollars out of his bank account
over his career there is plenty to get
through on this one he is one of the
great Lads it is Elijah Taylor welcome
mate hey James thanks for having me it's
good to be here mate awesome to have you
on like I said one of the craziest
stories I think the more people that can
hear this
um the better it's only going to do good
for
um other people in similar positions
that you were in at the time but crazy
career crazy stories
yeah unfortunately it wasn't didn't feel
nice at the time but you know we reflect
back you learn your lessons along the
way
um such as life you've been through up
and downs through your career some you
know pretty big highs and then some
pretty low lows but
um you just build character along the
way and hopefully
there's someone out there that's
listening to this podcast then I could
give them some viewpoints and give them
some tips of I suppose what not to do
yeah and some things what to do 100 that
let's start with the Featherstone Rovers
you're you're over there in the UK
living the dream um how are you finding
it yeah it's uh it's a bit of a step
down in intensity and in terms of we're
not playing in the Super League we're
trying to get up to Super League this
season they've done a big recruitment
Drive the club's really ambitious we're
trying to make it to the Top Flight
we're playing second division right now
we've got some good coaches I'm Sean
Long and Lynn on price they're St Helens
Legends for any rugby league fans out
there uh good coaches and
yeah it's a bit of a challenge for me
um stepping down to Second Division but
we are laying a foundation right now for
our preseason we're working really hard
uh season kicks off this Monday night we
play Keithley so yeah it's been a long
pre-season but the boys are Keen to
Ripon so how's your body how's your body
coping with another pre-season yeah
that's one of the biggest things so in
NRL your body gets destroyed with with
pre-seasons especially the wrestle in
contact sessions but over here it's more
focused on attack uh it's not as focused
on defense as back in the NRL and so
trainings are a lot easier uh and you're
not training in 40 degree 30 degree heat
like you are back in penrith or back in
Sydney
you're always you know you're training
in the snow sometimes with training when
it's always raining here you hardly see
the sun in pre-season so it's a lot
easier on the body compared to the NRL
yeah so you've got another few years
left in yeah because what are you now 32
yeah I'm 32. probably got maybe two
maybe one more year Lifting me yeah it
depends on depends on the body really if
I have a if I have a big injury I think
I'd call it yeah but
um until then body feels good and
immensely I feel good as well and as you
get older in your career you know
mentally that's the biggest one you've
got to try and Conquer every every
weekend every game day uh every
preseason massively yeah and how's the
family finding it because how many kids
have you got yeah they love it over here
I've got four girls four girls um yeah
my hand hands are full hands are full
but um yeah they like to hear the
education system I think it's a lot
better than Australia uh by far uh my
kids go to a public school they get free
uniform free iPads free stationery
uh free food it's weird over here like
um if my kids take a day off school like
the school's ringing me like where's
your kids like they're you know they're
really harsh on education which is a
good thing I think it's a good thing
anyway in life yeah
um so yeah the kids love it here do a
bit of traveling when I've got a weekend
off
um which is nice obviously Europe's just
across the uh the Water there so oh it's
been good it's been an experience for
all of us how good and obviously you're
talking about their educational
um systems but very different to your
upbringing I'd imagine obviously a proud
taranaki man
um I do always like to go back and hear
the journeys from the start so pretty
Keen to hear about what your childhood
was like and what your upbringing was
like and patea wasn't it yeah yeah South
America that's why I grew up in Parts
here I was born in older
um so part two is about 20 K's down the
road south of hawera small town dairy
farm I grew up with four brothers my dad
Ron Taylor he raised us on a dairy farm
so my childhood memories were milky cows
sheep fencing planting trees like just
order Farm stuff and you'll do as a farm
kid but after school you know there's
always some work to do on the farm
somewhere really enjoyed it because
obviously out of the farm you can
it gets up to a lot of stuff you know go
hunting go fishing go healing help out
the old man when he needs help
um
it's something you know when you when
you're young you take it for granted
massively
um like my kids growing up here it's so
cold we're hardly outside we're always
inside
um you can't really see the sun yeah and
so there's so much things in New Zealand
there's a New Zealand kid I took for
granted
uh but no I really enjoyed it I went to
a small school called Federal Credit
primary there were only 30 kids at the
school it went from
J1 up to Fourth standard four I think uh
and then I went to party high school for
two years
and then I then we moved up North with
my dad to Colorado a small town in the
far north
um and we moved all around there dad
looking for work and stuff
yeah but obviously rugby was that Union
yeah it was like the union yeah because
there's there's only Rugby Union in
taranaki and there's like pretty much
and when you went up north Rugby Union
was big as well you did get the old
League game on Sunday but
it wasn't consistent and it wasn't as
well set up as the union season yeah
what happened to the farm so we were
working on the farm so dad was a farm
hand so we used to he used to work on I
wish we owned it oh yeah
there's a big difference big difference
um uh sorry yeah we he was a fireman so
we just uh worked self-employed so
there's different Farmers around
kenokura and then we settled at the
Newlands and we worked there for about
four years it's good memories good times
is it true you're living out of your car
for for a while through your childhood
yeah that's when we moved up North so
it's right there was a random story bro
like I think Dad baycorp or after Dad he
wasn't paying his bills or something oh
yeah well it was just random we woke up
one morning he taught us to get in the
car from party we drew all the way up to
karaya which is like uh bro it's like a
seven hour drive from Parts taranaki all
the way up to the far north and then we
lived in like in a place called
perhaps the [__] wops and no power no
running water
why
yeah really bad it was family land up
there
um and so bro yeah that's when the
financial Year got hard and then yeah we
ended up in the car for about two months
because it was just two months yeah man
what was that yeah it was crazy where'd
you sleep just in the in the back seat
was what four brothers the last of my
two other brothers they moved to
Auckland with my mom yeah and it was me
and my other brother Gabriel
um with my dad up north in Colorado so
bro
those are probably the worst memories of
of my my childhood bro like living up
north
um you know I haven't got the best
memories up there but um
oh man it just makes you wanna
when you're young kid you just want to
succeed after you go through those
um stages in your life bro you just
thinking bro I'm not the one this when
I'm growing up like I wanna
I wanna play for the All Blacks bro I
want to play I'm not doing this man
um
to want to succeed when you go through a
pretty tough childhood true so is that
sort of you was that sort of your
motivation throughout your
um I guess early stages of your career
wanting to make it pro and in sport yeah
no like this time I was like 13
to 2003 2000
so we looked up door those years I went
to Colorado College
um but yeah definitely through those
Hard Times
um
yeah I think 2004 that's when the
Bulldogs won the Grand Final and I bro
Sonny Bill was killing in 2004 and then
yeah I just wanted to play league just
watching the games and then 2005 Benji
Marshall was playing tigers
um yeah just those players they inspire
and you know the circumstances you're in
as a kid they weren't good but
you know those
those Rugby League games are watching
those all black games when you're young
bro they do Inspire like young kids I
always definitely inspired by watching
Dan Carter and nonu and that
um
but I know hard times when I look back I
look back I'm grateful but at the time
bro I hated it did you get into much
trouble or were you getting into any
sort of
gang related stuff or did Sports sort of
keep you away from all that nah sports
sports kept me all the way from that and
my old man was pretty strict on me too
yeah
um and like living out in the on the
whops and a farm bro you ain't got
neighbors like you're in the middle of
paddocks and that so you can't really
get up to no good yeah
um
like there was a we were on a coast too
so there you go diving fishing for food
um you live off the land you know you're
in the garden
um
but just going through those experiences
at a young age
um you know really build your character
and build your drive but no I didn't get
into too much trouble like my dad used
to like grow weed in there but like you
never got quarters so yeah
but you were good at um Rugby Union too
weren't you you're making all the rep
teams Etc
um how did you how did you make that
transition over to League yeah so
obviously yeah unions
um that was all that was played in
tamanaki and there's all those played up
in up north
um
so
I started on Sundays at played rugby
league so I'd play rugby union on a
Saturday morning and on a Sunday morning
the boys used to throw together a lead
team randomly and then we would just go
and play
and then 2005 I moved down by my mum I
left there
she lives in Auckland
and um
she told me to try out for St Paul's
college and sign up because they played
first 15 on Saturday morning and they
played rugby league on the Wednesday
afternoon and their history of Warriors
that go through that school to get to
the Warriors
um there was a pathway
and so I jumped at that opportunity uh
2016. I went and signed up to go to St
Paul's College which was in Grayland in
the middle of Auckland City
and
yeah I was playing first of team that
they were in eighth grade too so they
were in the they played Auckland boys
they're very mags they played kelston
they played Saint Kent's so they were on
the top grade at the time and we played
rugby league on a Wednesday afternoon
after school
um and that's yeah so you play both get
the best of both worlds
um St Paul's College bro P was
compulsory I've never seen a school like
that but a college where every day you
had to do PE sure I'm sure that's
illegal but I remember I remember that
was the first call I've ever known for
there was pee every day yeah and that's
why a lot of sport players have come out
of St Paul's College in Auckland because
uh you know there's a rich history of
rugby league players playing for the
kiwis or playing for the Warriors that
come to their school what position were
you at Union Oz started opening and then
I went to inside Center oh yeah so I'd
still love to play like before I retire
I'd still love to have one season of of
Rugby Union just like even if it's
amateur or Semi-Pro like I'd still love
to do it get back to
midfielder for sure or or a seven making
70 tackles a game right you'll be right
on but apparently it's heaps technical
like all the interest intricacies of the
game like speaking to some players that
have done the crossover but no I'd love
to do it one day I'd love to do it
before I retire right how good would
that be so then you did get um picked up
by the Warriors a
um how did that one come about yeah so
on a Wednesday afternoon game we're
playing for Saint Paul's I think we
played mags and uh yeah after the game
uh Tony Oro the warrior Scout he was
just saying yeah um would you like to
come train with the development Squad
on I think it was Monday nights
Wednesday nights Friday nights and I was
like yeah man but I'll be there I'll be
there don't worry and uh that's how I
got into the Warrior system so I just
turned up it was for free there was no
contract he just told me to come and
come and train so I was training there
for about a year just turning up because
I was Keen as
um and then I just persevered persevered
I can't see the other side but um yeah I
went there I met yeah some some Young
Warriors Sunny fire it was the first
player I met and Lee Sonoma I met him we
were all young kids then Isaac John I
met man uh Russell pack always young Ben
Malino was young
and now we had a good little crew there
and by all accounts you uh you're
training uh intensity was sort of At a
next level one of the boys told me that
they remember going back to Mount smart
at like 11 p.m one day to pick up some
protein or something and you were in the
gym in the pitch black just biking 100K
on the bike just for some sort of David
Goggins mad stuff so is that sort of sum
up your training ethic
thank you
um overall it's just that desperate I I
was so desperate to
uh just get a first grade contract
um
yeah look look back at the times he's
just always trying to chase uh
you know trace a full-time gig
um you know whenever we trialed against
first grade like during the week so
under 20s would play
the Warriors first grade team just in an
opposed session but it was like the
biggest day of my week like because you
know Ivan's watching you know John
eglin's watching the first grade coaches
so you want to impress well I was a
teach desperate Road especially for my
childhood and what I went through as a
young kid
um you only get one Shopper I want you
know one opportunity and then you're a
tree rapper
but yeah I was just really Keen really
desperate bro to change my family's
circumstances to be able to look after
my family
at a young age I knew that was my
opportunity and I had to take it and you
had a lot of success with that New
Zealand 20s group at the time or The
Warriors 20 group at the time you
mentioned a lot of those players who are
in your team but
um you had a really successful time
you're a captain as well weren't you so
um what are your memories of those games
and that success uh 2008 yeah first year
of under 20s that was a tough
competition I remember you know we're
all young then like Shawn Johnson was
young
um right yeah Benny matzel's young
suddenly fire was young
Lee sung um it was probably the hardest
training I've ever done it was my first
proper pre-season
um
and I remember like on our first day we
got our kit and warriors are sponsored
by Puma so we've got all these Puma
gears got all these Puma shoes and I was
just like
this is crazy I used to scratch the Puma
make sure it didn't rip off so it's like
legit so it's like yeah because I never
got those clothes when I was young bro I
never got those clothes and I used to
think yeah we got so many gears then we
were staying at the Crown Plaza and kuji
were staying at Crowne plazas all over
Australia we get to fly in New Zealand
I'd never flown out of the country
before like growing up
suspend the Kuru Lounge all the time
like bro I used to love it because we
were only 17 young kids
um
yeah good memories there a lot of
success
obviously so much competition to get
into that team because the whole in New
Zealand the Warriors have got the hole
in New Zealand to choose from and
then the next year all the first 15 boys
started coming to Conrad Harrell uh
Solomon Carter because all the Warriors
started signing the best first 15 guys
Curtis Roan I think he came uh or else
yeah a lot of a lot of boys came through
because obviously it was an attractive
um for young teenagers you know you sign
Semi-Pro contracts you get the flight
Australia every second weekend
uh yeah so if you're a young kid you're
a teenager you've got a rugby and League
why wouldn't you give it a crack and
you're on TV every week too weren't you
so yeah yeah stardom and all that side
of it that kids want to chase earlier
rather than later eh yeah so yeah just
we're so fortunate the Warriors man the
Warriors I look back now and the worries
was broke we got so much stuff as young
kids like they're sponsored by Vodafone
so we all got our iPhone as soon as the
new iPhone dropped and we all got credit
and we all got like Air New Zealand
airpoints as young kids like I look back
now this was 2008 and I was just like
bro I was so ungrateful back then like
we used to get things handed to us
whenever we wanted but
you realize when you come to over here
and the game's struggling like you're
getting none of that you may get hooked
after but I taught you I taught you
quickly how to be a professional too
like
get into the airport on time training on
time recovery how do you recover after a
game eating well
um I think you know that that
competition really put players in good
stead to set them up for in our own
career
um and I think they've I don't think the
worries ever under 20s anymore I'm not
sure but no that definitely was a
pathway like
there was an easy pathway like you could
see it you go from school you go to the
Warriors development you go to Warriors
under 20s reserves and then first grade
debut like the the pathway was clear so
they've got to sort their back out for
sure sounded like it was too expensive
to yeah right yeah it sounded like you
were living the life Vodafone Eric
Watson they just must have been like
here you boys
yeah
but you did get a call up into the first
grade team
um not too long later eh but then we
injured you missed the missed your
opportunity due to a hammy wasn't it bro
the worst bro the worst story ever like
I hadn't been injured for like three
years no injuries at all
um yeah and then Ivan gave me a call on
the Tuesday 2009
um
yeah during 2009 I used to always wait
for my phone Monday morning or Monday
night just in case either might call me
bro
I used to always have my phone just make
sure if I come on man come on
um and then Tuesday yeah there's one
Tuesday night he called me and said I
was playing David Bowie
um I think it was against Gold Coast
back home brand old stoked started
crying ring there he started crying rang
mom we started crying
and then at Captain's Room like I wasn't
even I wasn't even running fast I did my
Hemi I did a grade two Hemi just by
taking off
and like I'd given tickets out to my dad
like I got a box ready in there oh bro
so it was pretty embarrassing so I did
my hammy and Captain Joe
and then I couldn't I couldn't play for
the next three weeks and that's the
first time I've been into three three
years bro
all right that's heartbreak oh man and
then
or when it's a first grade preseason my
first grade first actual preseason with
first grade
and then the week before the trial
I did an ACL doing ladders ah lad doing
letters bro I did an ACL doing ladders
that's crazy
um and that was right before our first
trial so I was out for the whole season
um
because uh you know I just missed my
debut by doing a hammy and Captain's
Room and then I do my ACL before my
first grade season so
there's a lot of setbacks when you're a
young kid but again you know just
character building you know you learn
from those and
it's become more grateful I suppose how
did you get through that uh mentally
like as a young kid obviously so excited
to be about to have your NRL taper then
it's taken away and then obviously the
next year pretty much taken away from
you too must have been tough mentally oh
definitely right and but this is when
Ian miles comes into the picture because
he's a sports psychologist
yeah and oh he was is he and
um
that's what I mean him had an awesome
relationship from that point because I
was going through all these setbacks and
I was thinking like why is this
happening to me like why what have I
done wrong
um and that's saying yeah me and him
used to you know spend a lot of time
that's when I got into the Pinnacle
program what's the Pinnacle program so
it was a program where young aspiring
New Zealand athletes are trying to get
to the Pinnacle of this sport so um Adam
Hall he was a skier
um he had spina bifida but he won Gold
and by two Paralympics some
Peter Taylor they had all done it
um
so they've done the program and then I
applied for the program and then I got
into the program
and um Ian ran the program and that's
how I built a really good relationship
with him through 2009 when I was going
through my ACL rehab
um
and that's how our relationship kind of
started
yeah and then how did it Grow from the
obviously you were speaking term about
your injuries and stuff and he was well
I guess mentoring you through how to get
back
how does it sort of go to that next
level where it becomes like you know
your best mate
I suppose you know you've gone through
big injuries yourself
um yeah it can be some dark times going
on thing you're watching all the boys
having fun and you'll just don't know
what bike or you're just on a rowing
machine just getting flogged every every
training session
um
like he introduced me to storm you
introduced me to Peter Taylor he
introduced me to Olympic athletes and
that's when his credibility was like
started
um going right believable definitely
yeah we spent time with them
um and they all spoke really well there
and
um and he did a lot of yeah
sports psychology work with me through
the through the Pinnacle program
um
and yeah we serve a lot of
heart-to-heart conversations about about
life about my upbringing about
yeah a lot of deep topics that not many
other
I swear Sports Sykes would do and he
always had time for me but he'd always
like I could talk I could call him I
could text him he'd always reply
and just over three years of doing that
constantly
just build my trust from
and yeah that's pretty much how
the relationship just got better and
better between me and him like uh and
there's no one else in my family I could
turn to for this kind of information
like my old man he's a Dairy Farmer
right like what do you know in a sport
kind of thing
um you know no no uncles or aunties that
could give advice
you know financially like no one you
know there's no one in my family I could
turn to kind of thing but yeah and he
was in bro like
responsible Hyundai
um
he mentored Olympic athletes
um and they all spoke really well of
them
and so I just thought it was a win-win
for myself I was like yeah man I've got
someone in my corner that can help me
out
on the field mentally
it helped me out financially could help
you know give me some good advice
and yeah but um
that's how the relationship got really
good and what sort of like Financial
advice was he giving you to
sort of gain his trust to give you the I
guess permission for him to have access
to your accounts in the end uh Opera
we're setting up trust like you showed
me what a trust was I don't know what
truss was like yeah they introduced me
to accountant Bradley accountant was and
like all this kind of stuff because
obviously my upbringing like there's not
much of those conversations going around
um
and and bro just just a constant uh
being able to relay information to him
and he would introduce me to I don't
know
a Hyundai CEO or the New Zealand sport
psychologist and I talked to him about
um
they're dealing in the same
his wife is a
real estate agent in Christchurch so I
speak to her for a little while like
about you know maybe investing in the
house or what should I do kind of thing
like
so it gave me a lot of different options
um and again there's no one in my family
I could turn into kind of then so I
thought I was 19 years old and I thought
bro like this guy's gonna help me out
big time
and I was really grateful for it too
because
Adam have known as the turnt economy it
sounds all so legit hey like right next
to you talk about it like do you think
it was legit at the time like he was
genuinely he started off the process
really genuine or do you think it was
his plan from the start
see
heads will start genuine because there
were so many times we've spent so long
talking he invited me into his house I
met his son I met his wife uh we had
lunch we had breakfast together
[Music]
he took me to go surfing with razor
Robinson
you know all these things are just
building my trust like every time he's
doing it I'm just like oh bro
yeah like I used to fly me to
Christchurch Queenstown just to meet
razor yeah
um because he thought you know raise
will be really good you know if you
learn off him
and I was like yeah man sweet
um just setting up all these meetings
for me and you know I was 19 years old
you know just broken the first grade and
um I think it was genuine at the start
definitely definitely was genuine and um
and then
yeah obviously you know what happens
about down the road you just start
thinking of things what he said back
then he was like wow no surely not like
hindsights
you know
yeah there's a towards the back end
there's a few things we just like bro
what was I even think in there yeah but
after like five years six years of
relationship build the trash
everything was kosher bro everything was
cool like yeah I met a lot of sort of
Crusaders play as well Ash Parker
one of the other boys but they took me
to a game they took me to a Canterbury
game back in the days like
yeah and Ian was working with them as
well so yeah he's got to be legit so
then your decision to make him because
he becomes your manager in the end
doesn't he he becomes your own personal
manager yeah what was that how did you
get to that point with to make that
decision for him to take over uh so we
made the decision together after we're
having lunch at our dinner at the stamp
uh hotel in Auckland
and I just thought it was a no-brainer
for me well honestly I didn't think
twice about it
especially after
all we've been through
um I was you know my dad died as well
and he like you know helped me through
that process as well where like he was
there all the time and that made me even
trust him even more
um but
yeah we both come to the decision I
thought it was a great decision but I'll
remember talking to my teammates they
were complaining about their manager
because they never hear from their
manager and I was saying bro I hear from
a manager like every day nearly like
every every week and they were
complaining that they only hear from
their manager when their contracts up
so I was like cheering
the whole time because I thought I was
in good hands everything seemed legit
um yeah and so we made that decision
together and then he went and got an
accredited because at the NRL if you
want to be a manager you've got to be in
the credits and manager so you've got to
go through a lot of process so this
stuff doesn't happen
it still happened yeah
yes that's another that's another him
that's another one
and then he got you a contract yeah yeah
so that's when I signed with a pair of
panthers oh yeah
yeah looking back
the warrior is offered me a deal I
thought it was great
and he was like no no don't sign it
here's a print of deal just wait another
year and in hindsight if I signed that
contract he wouldn't get any of that
money oh yeah so that's what he wanted
me to wait another year to sign the
Penrose contract that's when he got the
money so they're just things like that
you just start noticing you looking back
and you're just like bro that was yeah
that was the setup kind of thing
um but yeah like
and that's when I went to uh the
Panthers but at the time like I would
have loved to stay at the Warriors
because I was that's when I grew up
that's what my daybrew with
um I wasn't too Keen to go but I was
just listening to Ian's advice he was
just like no this is the best thing for
you this is
um where you want to go for your your
career to get better
it's crazy all it was was better for his
pocket yeah yeah
and he's got full access to your
accounts at this stage yeah at that
stage so as soon as I signed the penrith
deal
a month later the the World Cup 2013's
on oh yeah so I'm gonna fly to England
in like November I think October
and so I shoot the penrith open up all
my penrith Banks accounts
um and he's already organized that which
bank accounts how's it going to be set
up and everything obviously I trusted I
was like yeah right here you set it up
I'll go to World Cup and he was like
yeah cool I'll take care of it
and then
by looking back obviously it's stupid
but at the time bro I just thought yeah
man you take care of that I'll just
focus on training at 40 and you you do
that I'll be cool and he gave you like
an allowance was it like was it four
thousand a month or something to live
off for you and your family yeah yeah he
looked after the rest
yeah so
obviously there was
what we had agreed to
and I was caught that man because I was
just like okay you sit there I'll just
focused on playing my best footage for
pin Rev
um they try and play for the kiwis again
and um just focus on footy I don't have
to worry about anything else
and you know yeah obviously he was like
yeah that's sweet that's fine that's all
cool
um
yeah man I never questioned it
for three years and and the boys were
saying to me when they found out all
this all the boys were like what are you
dumb guy you didn't check your bank
account for three years are you serious
that's what they all told me now I was
just like bro I never had to kind of
thing like
I just had to focus on 40 as long as I
you know all my bills are paid which
they were like
groceries petrol
supplements whatever
then I could just play my best for you
bro and they'll just you know my
teammates probably taking this Mickey
and I was just like I can't believe you
didn't take your but I'm not a punner
like and I hardly went out with the boys
so I don't need to check my bank account
because I don't gamble I don't right
yeah no I'll put on I stay at home all
the time why
[Music]
I guess a lot of people as soon as that
especially when they're making decent
money the first thing they like to check
at payday is how much is sort of rolled
into the account but you were pretty
strict and you got your 4 000 trusted
miles as you would
um to look after the restaurant vest
um that money into good things for you
because you obviously felt like he had
your best interest at heart eh oh bro
definitely well after all we've been
through for like eight years been
through ups and downs my career my ACL
my dad dying
um and all the mentorship
you know him flying me around New
Zealand to like meet razor to meet
Canterbury players
bro I just yeah that's how he got my 100
Trust
and uh
obviously in hindsight it hurts a bit
but
during the time bro I thought I was onto
a winner like I thought but this one is
the man while he's looking after me so
it's all good was he your best man at
your wedding too so that shows you sort
of how far the relationship went
Yeah the more I think about it just the
more things
I thinking was I thinking
um
but yeah we so my wife's my wife's
uncle's a pilot um Sean so he taught me
a lot
um and so here you've got tickets to
icedentucky if you've ever been to
istock anyway if anyone's been to ice
turkey bro it's a beautiful place like
it's crazy beautiful
yeah and like he got free tickets we've
got free tickets to take uh Ian and his
wife like on the detour and that just
things like that you just look back and
just like man
kind of hurts a bit yeah um yeah it kind
of hurts a bit but uh
yeah I suppose you learn learn from
those mistakes man yeah all these
awesome memories in your life you've got
but then you've also got this memory of
Ian miles just hanging around the
background too just ruining all your
memories stop
true and then did he get you to the
Tigers how did that one work well yeah
this kind of when the red flags have
started going off okay so I had a really
good relationship with Ivan at the
Warriors really good relationship and
before I ever lifted the parents
Panthers he said if you're Keen to come
like I'll bring it over and so I was
like yeah sweet
and so my relationship with Ivan pretty
much got me the penrith deal like pretty
much and then either got fired from
penrith 2015.
2015 I've got five on penrith
and then Anthony Griffin came into
penrith and just did a big clean out and
I was one of the players that
were getting pushed on
and
yeah Ian didn't really have any other
options for me and I was 25 at the time
so I was living in my Prime kind of
thing
and he had not he had nothing on the
table for me
um
and then we got through halfway of the
2016 season
and the Tigers were Keen uh for
a lock they needed a lock
um to play for them
and the Tigers of the CEO was also used
to be the Tigers of
the penis Panthers and I had a really
good relationship with Justin pesko
and I think my relationship with Justin
kind of made the deal easier to go to
penrith it wasn't really Ian's
your ability to like get a contract kind
of thing so
so that's when I moved to the Tigers for
the rest of 2016.
and then um
I played really good for the Tigers in
my first year there
and then Ian still wasn't wasn't able to
get another contract beyond that
and that's when I started
thinking something something's not right
here because surely like I'm only 26
yeah and
he said I was close to going to the
Crusaders like Crusaders were putting
together
the deal I think he was just talking it
up because that never happened yeah
but you know you he's always say razor
high he raises trying to organize
something for you and that never comes
yeah that never come to Russian so I
just think he was just saying that would
you have made the switch
probably not bro yeah probably not
because if I went to rugby then I've got
to start again and I probably wouldn't
be on the same as much money as I was
playing rugby league
playing like Super Rugby in there so
um
yeah but he used to always bring it up
you know I've racist emailed me kind of
thing like
I don't even know if that was true
yeah oh ask him tomorrow but right that
sounds that sounds crazy but you're at
the Tigers for how many years were the
Tigers in the end you you must have got
that extension in the end how did he get
there
so the end of 2016 that's when I found
out everything about Ian
um
yeah yeah so and that's when his
contract was up
um how'd you find out oh we got a
mortgage we've got a mortgage bill so
all of my bank account bills they went
to Ian's
suggestions
so you know maybe that was a setup as
well like so all of my banking bills
everything went to his house in
Christchurch
sure uh but we got one for late mortgage
repainting
one randomly one day
and then yeah opened up I was like
there's no way we could be behind like
no way yeah and then they're like you're
such and such behind I was just like nah
and then
yeah jumped on the bank accounts
and then I was just like
yeah and then we went to we went
straight to Westpac and penrith
into the um
into the shop kind of thing and then
that's when I found out bro it was crazy
all right y'all never forget that day
um
and then once Ian was out of the picture
I negotiated the entire this contract
myself and
got it over the line so it was It was
kind of
it was kind of good in a way but
um that's how I got my next contract was
just me talking to Justin and Ivan
because Ivan went to the Tigers as well
so
that's how that worked out all right
that's crazy so when you saw all those
transactions
in your bank statement
what are you thinking
this can't be true bro I remember
looking at the screen yeah like in one
of those cubicles at Westpac they turned
the screen to you you know yeah I was
like nah
and then you just scroll down and you
just keep scrolling and like you just
keep going and I was just like bro
and then he scroll down right to the end
and then showed the total figure and I
was just like what
and then he said oh that's only 2014. oh
and then it showed me 2015. right
oh bro he just scroll
scrolling for
you and then he was like oh here's 2016.
and then he was showing me all those
transactions oh you know
and he said oh let me show you the
credit card and I was just like oh bro
no way
and yeah it's just
yeah that was actually my reaction just
doing these ones
um
but yeah so uh we got everything printed
out checked out on the USB
um
I sent it to the rugby uh rugby league
players Association
in Australia bro they're really good
um to help me out gave me some advice
uh Sound Advice it was good and that's
where it went from there man all right
what was your wife's reaction what was
she thinking through the whole for the
through the whole experience I guess did
she ever have
um a suspicion I told you
[Laughter]
see oh yeah because she just saying I
told you I told you I was just like wow
because there was a few times like
um one time yeah I went over my four
thousand and I was like
we'll just ask for asking for more money
yeah sweet and Ian was like oh no we
can't we can't get use that money until
your next pay comes in
and I I when he sit there I was like
it's all right but then she was like no
they can't be wrong but I kind of kept
her out of everything I didn't really
share what me and Ian are doing kind of
thing
wow
uh yeah right
but um God bless him and like
yeah she's been through me with me
through those tough times I
um actually it really helped me
supported me
through that through that
yeah really grateful for her man did you
think you were going to get that money
back or did you or did you when you saw
that were you like oh this is gone or
you're always hopeful that you're going
to be getting that back because
obviously someone just can't steal four
hundred thousand dollars out of your
your bank account can they
at the stop right I was obviously naive
to the law I didn't know much about the
law and how it works what a civil court
case what's a criminal court case how
does the laws of the work of New Zealand
how do the laws work in Australia no
obviously I was thinking bro just go and
arrest him get my money back done yeah
like you know
how simple is that how hard is that how
hard is that honestly got all the
evidence
um
but when yeah like so I was pretty
confident I was going to get it back
because I thought it'd be easy process
like a few phone calls yeah sorry mate
yeah here you go Dragon back yep cool uh
but yeah there definitely wasn't to be
the longer the process went on and the
closer we got to court
before I engaged with chairmanship
lawyers
they were just giving me a legal advice
and they'll just legal advice and they
were saying
the chances of him declaring bankruptcy
is pretty high
and they were looking over his record I
mean they said he's done it before
true and so he's probably gonna do it
again oh wow
and this is after one year of just
talking with the rrpa
The Players Association in Australia by
just trying to
now should we go through the Australian
courts should we go to the New Zealand
courts because it was Australian bank
account obviously
um
and then we decided yeah New Zealand
courts and then we decided Chapman trip
Garth bro you helped me out so much
woolies helped me out so much I'm really
thankful for them at Chapman trip but
yeah the closer we got to the day the
more feeling was just like bro I'm not
going to give this money back kind of
thing and then a week before we finally
get to court which took what four years
just to get to court three years oh yes
yeah from from the day I found out so
you got to the court right that was like
three years
that's a long time of just simmering on
yeah on all of it just stewing on all of
the brain just like you know when you do
this hard training like doing a
conditioning session and you start
thinking negative thoughts right that
was the first thing they come to my mind
for I was just Ian Pops in bruh what am
I doing like why am I doing this why am
I doing this wrestle session yeah um
but yeah it finally got to court and
then two weeks before the court case it
was like oh I'm bankrupt
I got no money I've got mental health
issues I can't make it to court
even though the Court's like 200 meters
from this house uh walking distance
um
it's crazy like back in the sports like
days he used to always tell me
um
corruption and Sport he used to always
tell me like
they like tell me things about it while
he was actually doing and I was just
like was he taking the piss
very like
um yeah and then
so the court case happened
got the result
on all charges you're proven
privier proven guilty
order to pay back what 450
450k I think 500k and they're just
saying he's bankrupt got no money and
got mental health issues you can't touch
me
pretty much
and um
that was it bro
hey this makes my blood boil a when I
listen to it it's so frustrating how how
someone can just do that and claim
bankruptcy and then what get away and he
lives in Christchurch right right in the
center of the city like a nice ass house
and his wife's mortgage free 100
bro
it just makes you won those just makes
you wonder just like you know what the
heck's what that's not fair like it
can't be fair yeah how does that work
and then my lawyers were like oh there's
people that do that all the time and I
was just like wow like the place you
know kind of makes you question a lot of
things from society kind of thing like
um just our trusts work and lots of
trust and how they're set up to protect
people when this does happen
um
so I learned a lot about the legal
system and about the law
yeah I was just trying to take some
positives out of it bro like
well I'm gonna find the positive
somewhere a four hundred thousand dollar
lawyer education oh man
yeah and then um
so after that
um
they said oh you know take it to the
police they might be able to help you
out
so I took the court case to the police
just gave him the file you know
succeeding in the Civil Court
to New Zealand Police they gave it to
them and then they were like no we're
not going to do anything and I was just
like
okay
what do you mean
bro like 450 000 from me you got
evidence in your lap and you're not
going to do anything and they're like no
he's a little bit old like you know he's
no threat to anybody else and I was just
right
yeah all right and you see that uh
claimed bankruptcy before so he had had
he done this before the whole the whole
process of that before or I don't I
don't know so my lawyers I don't know
how they found that information but they
told me like when they when they did it
I don't know to check on them or
something but yeah it came up that he
declare bankrupt before but this is way
before yeah
when he used to race motorbikes
but um
yeah he never told me that in this
sports like stuff
there's a lot he left out
um
Yeah man so that's how that's how that
unfolded so did you ever speak to him
once you found out what was your like
communication obviously you spoke every
day multiple times when you guys were
good but once you found out once you
sent him that file of what had actually
gone on what was your comms like
that was it
I sent him a screenshot
I think a screenshot of
of the bottom of the total oh yeah
yeah and a question mark
and there's the last I've heard from
them personally what about in court or
anything no no you didn't even shut up
sorry nothing
um obviously I read what he said to his
lawyer through his lawyer but I read it
on a piece of paper
um
yeah but contact wise no I saw sorry I
saw him in a mediation meeting
early 2017 but we hardly spoke I just
shook his hand and the lawyers were just
talking
um this was in Christchurch
but that was the last time I had any
contact with him
yeah
it's just so crazy bro like
you just never think that would happen
and never think that especially like
what you've been through
and for that to happen he is pretty
pretty
yeah I don't want to happen to anybody
else for sure no way
no way how can you stop it what would
your advice be for obviously guys in
similar situations
um how would you have how would you
avoid that in hindsight because
obviously he went through a fair amount
of detail to get your trust and
he put a lot into it yeah
um honestly bro just simple notification
on your phone connected to your bank
yeah look as soon as something happens
in your bank you get a notification on
the phone yeah well I didn't I didn't I
didn't know if that if I had
like I saw
a trip to Fiji pop up on my freaking
Fiji something pop up on my
my notifications you just checked into
the Hilton PG and I'm just like what the
like to something simple like that like
if you're out there and yeah just
notifications connected to your phone
yeah anything touches your bank account
you get a notification straight away
and that that would have saved me so
much time they want to save all of this
man because you know if I saw what I
thought you came in I would have got an
application and then
that was it how did he make sure that
you weren't checking your bank account
or did he just
was he just lucky that you're one guy
that never checked his bank account he
was a sports like man so he knew me
inside out so he knew what I was like
honestly he knew
like if I played a bad game
and we'll talk after it he knew exactly
what I was going to say like he knew
okay that's how well he knew me after
like eight years
um and again there was no reason to
check my bank account like I wasn't
making
massive
um purchases or anything
the boys will call me a tight ass bro
because I never went out with them and
had coffees and that they were like oh
you tell us like you're shot because I'm
not bro
shouting miles
um
yeah but I never had Subaru right and
I'm not a punter too so I'm not like
dipping and getting money to put on a
bet like so
yeah what was he spending your money on
did you ever you obviously saw all that
yeah
hotels bro like
going to those expensive like Pandora
shops and all that shops in Sydney like
right in the city because I lived in
penrith and it's kind of the sticks
imperative compared to like Sydney City
but after like leaving Peter if you'd
stay like two nights and ride on darling
Harbor like flash Hotel
bro like crazy gifts for his wife
like I didn't even think my wife there
to get those stuff
and he says yeah we're just racking up
um like flights to
flights to Fiji like flights to
Melbourne
hotels in Melbourne because the son
Jordy lives in Melbourne
um oh yeah he like runs the F1 down
there or something
um
do you ever interesting all those
transactions are you just like wow crazy
yeah
and honestly like moving some money to
their trust obviously because you know
you can't touch it once it goes into
someone's trust so it's
um
another one oh mate so crazy and then
you um you obviously finish your time
with the Tigers
and then you make your decision to head
over to the UK why'd you why'd you
decide to head over there so my contract
was up at the tigers
um Madge he was the coach at the time at
the time said like they're not going to
resign me so that was cool he was
upfront about it
um
I was hoping this was in the 2020
and I was deep in my um my CPR my my
pilot studying at the time
um so I was just focused on getting my
license
um and I I was pretty content with footy
after that especially after going
through like all me and miles and stuff
like that I had enough of footy man I
was just like bro I need to do something
different
because this that was draining man three
years that just being on your mind all
the time
yes I that's when I ripped into my pilot
study and um
towards the end of the back end of 2020
my manager was looking for something
else Tyron Smith
he um he helped me out a lot through
this whole process as well show up to
Thai
um so he was looking but I was more
focused on getting my license and then
going to the airlines oh yeah that's
what I was focused on doing and going to
apply for Qantas
that's what I wanted to do straight
after 2020 and that's what I planned and
then covert hit
and then all the Airline jobs gone just
like that yeah that's right yeah they're
all gone and I just got my license too
got all my tickets ready to go to the
airlines
and then no one was hiring
um
and then Ty said look mate there's
opportunity to go Salford are you
interested two years and I was just like
yeah Brave it out because there's no way
I'm getting
into the airlines now because covert has
shut down everything and so that's when
I made this decision to
come to Salford come to the UK it was a
great challenge it was a good
opportunity
I always wanted to come play Super
League one day
heard a lot of good stories about it uh
past players
glad I did
um yeah some awesome experiences so far
and uh that's how I ended up in in
Salford because covert pretty much made
me come in crazy so you were done you in
your mind you were mentally done with
footy and you're ready to be a pilot
yeah
oh the way Michael McGuire trains like
he's got a reputation burn off like hard
ass training yeah which is absolutely
true absolutely true like he's a man of
his word man like the way we trained at
Targets
right I've never trained that hard
physically before and I've done a lot of
hard trainings but it was mainly the
contact
because it was really big on like full
contact yeah strap up mouth guard
running straight
100 and we did that for like sometimes
hour 40. oh sounds like a nightmare oh
bro like when you're 30 years old bro
you don't want to be
honestly just get the ball run the team
readers as hard as you can and some
Benny manolino and Russell Packer bro
just wrong just getting smashed and you
just keep doing that for bro make
anyway bro that training was so odd and
that was I was sick of 40 I was just
like nah but I'm not doing this again
and then um
yeah that's a nice like bro I've gone
through the EMR stuff I'm off that
to the the two seasons of match
trainings was crazy hard I'm off that so
I was just
I was over 40 Grand I was gonna stop I
was gonna finish and then that gave me
more motive to study hard and like
get through my theory exams because I
knew that the end date was coming but
that is a hard exam for all accounts is
is to get your pilot license so yeah
juggling that while playing footy
um no wait no I mean fee how did you
manage to do that
Yeah by those Theory exams there were a
lot of times where I was thinking bro
I'm like way I'm way even too deep like
this is way too big this is way too hard
for me kind of thing
um
but I knew I had nothing to fall back on
like if I had a big ACL like Brian
nothing I was a footy player all my
teenage years
until I was 30 and there was nothing and
I had kids I had responsibilities
you know I I had to provide
um
and that's what gave me the energy and
motivation to just keep trying to crack
this exam
flight planning atpi flight planning
like any Pilots out there they'll know
that's the hardest exam because you've
only got a certain amount of time to do
crazy calculations and if you get one
thing wrong in the calculations the
exams go on all right but you know that
was really tough really tough time but
I was just over it man I was over
training so in between trainings that
were coming in the morning we'll do 40
like conditioning and that and then
we'll have like a hour break so I do
some study during the hour break on my
car or I'll go on the massage room or
acquire room
um and do some study and then we'll do
weights and then
I have a feed and do some study at the
same time on my phone or these exams on
my phone were pretty sweet and then
we'll do wrestle after that
and then when I get home I just study
um
one of my off Seasons so in our off
season we have
five weeks off six weeks off
I think yeah
and then brah sacrifice no holiday I
just stayed home and studied bro like
because I knew I knew I was under
pressure because I got responsibilities
in that and um I was over football I
kind of hated it made me hated it after
a while especially with all the pressure
in the NRL too like
playing that kind of game being
scrutinized every week
the depth that was coming through at the
time
and uh yeah but I was just over the
pressure that's unreal that's unreal
um drive from you to be able to juggle
all that sacrifice your your off season
um to get to get it done and and you've
got it now and is that what you want to
do Post footy once you finish is that is
that still the dream yeah so
um as soon as I finish here I'll
probably shoot back to Australia and
then apply
of it I've got to get current on my
Landing so I've got a current on my I
I'm like how to land an aircraft because
if you haven't landed for a while you
lose your currency so you've got to do a
refresher yeah you always got to do a
refresher but you've got to pass that
refresher so I've got to give through
all that again
I don't have to do any exams I just
gotta do a flight test and show that I'm
I'm capable of doing it and then I can
apply it for the Airlines and that yeah
good what's it what's the dream Airline
I don't know man like what I was just my
mate that helped me out his name's um
Ben Harris he's a player for the
Bulldogs back in the days 2004.
um he's a captain for Qantas and he so
he helped me out a lot like with
studying that
and so he was trying to get me in the
door there so hopefully
if I go back
There's an opportunity to um
how good would that be big Captain
Taylor speaking over the
the
announcer how good right now I'm looking
forward to it because I know my body's
going to be wrecked there's not much I'm
going to be able to do especially after
playing rugby league for you know 15
years my knees my shoulders so
yeah it's a job that I could do without
being in pain kind of thing yeah but
there's another job you're you're pretty
damn good at too um Boy music the rapper
uh
how weird is this set does this is this
like the Ultimate Dream would you love
to take rapping full time uh
I don't know I think like I'm pretty
boxed in with the content that I can
talk about
um and I think
I've always liked hip-hop when I was
since I was young used to always listen
to heaps of rap like
all the time
um I don't listen to as much as of today
but but yeah in park biggie pun
like heaps
um that's you know when you grow up to
your child childhood that's all I
remember like just listening to that
kind of music
um so it was always a hobby like
so whenever the Warriors will fly I'd be
making music on my iPad of when the
hotels all the time are warriors so
there's always heaps of time on your
hands to try and do something make some
music in that so I really enjoyed that
aspect of it as well and the freedom and
create creativity that you can do with
it uh but I don't see it like being get
to like two big like yeah I'm just doing
that as a hobby at the moment and I
think it's about to explode I've been
I've been jamming your music on the way
to work the last few weeks right
lyrically one of the greats no like as
long as I try and get a positive message
out through through my music like I'll
never rap about as I was talking about
I'll pretty box myself in so I'm not
going to be talking about like women
money cars like all the all the stuff
that
most artists talk about now bro that's
just it's not edifying it's not
encouraging at all like
so I don't even listen to the rap I used
to listen to when I was a young kid
because yeah I was pretty negative as
well
um
so yeah so that's probably why that it's
not gonna get any bigger because I'm
pretty boxed into what I can talk about
and like I'll never swear in a song I'll
never never swear in my song so that's
you know half of it gone so
um but no it's a hobby I enjoy
um
and something I like doing and takes my
mind away from footy as well
it's pretty relaxing too because you can
be creative There's No Boundaries kind
of things so no it's cool I enjoy it
would you be confident to jump up on
stage and perform like your songs in
front of you know sold out Mount smart
probably not not at the moment not at
the moment but not at the moment no way
no
um
I don't know one day maybe but no not at
the moment it's way too shy for that I I
haven't struggle like recording myself
in a video clip I struggle doing that
it's like no I'm looking like an idiot
as I put that mask on
yeah so yeah I can't get over there
oh mate well whatever you choose no
doubt you're going to be successful with
the drive that you've shown but as
always mate I've gone to the Instagram
for some questions and yeah cool um got
some good ones pop up obviously the
first one's about your um wrapping uh
when's the album dropping a lot of the
fans want to know when boy music's big
albums dropping first time on the
shelves
bro I'll I'll never charge anything for
my stuff it's always going to be free on
YouTube I'll never I'll never change
it's gonna be free on Spotify
that's how music's consume now like yeah
if you're a young there's no point
selling it like you just got to get it
out there and
um
because anybody can bootleg any music
like there's no point
um sorry you know I thought about that I
was just like no right it's always put
on YouTube
it's all free anyone can listen to it
more reach
so
I'll probably just do singles jobs I'll
probably never because I think the days
of albums are gone like this this hobby
any time you'd sit there and go through
a whole album yeah like because
everyone's got a shuffle playlist
playlist Spotify I like everything's on
shuffle now so I think singles are the
ways ago is like Drop singles drop
singles are you working on one at the
moment when's the next single dropping
oh no I'm doing a freestyle I'm doing a
freestyle at the moment I'm just doing
the finishing touches on the editing and
that
but I noticed the freestyles they get
more reaction I think I don't know why
but
even though I'm talking about so many
different subjects
um
but they get the most reactions so I'll
just I'll just keep doing that oh how
good and the next one's actually on
that's from your good mate Ben matolino
uh can you drop us a freestyle
freestyle
[Music]
um
oh yeah sweet uh glad to get up
a lot of Uncertain bottled up you've
probably been hurting and had enough and
the body is hurting but mentally you got
to get up it's hard when you're shaking
happy thoughts should you Dagger from
working now you've got a problem with
burdens turning into these hurdles
hearing voices with negative verbals
your honesty's becoming concerning then
the drama is nurtured You observe it you
gotta go purge it saying is it really
worth it gone from a hobby to work you
know you bother trying to make your game
perfect because I'm sitting in the lobby
and I really want to stop and I'm
learning if I cop another shot in the
sternum
and I promise it's burning my brother
say I'm soft and reversing God dropped
the reserves it's not enough trying to
follow the person I want to be like
Jonathan Thurston but I gotta get up
you got it
wow that is one of the greatest
freestyles I've ever heard Right In the
Flesh oh how good is that how do you how
do you write these or how do you come up
with these just
right usually after a game or after a
concession I don't know nothing you know
after a conversation Will's hard and but
you feel real good yeah like when you're
having a shower and you're like feeling
good like yeah
like those are the times where I get the
most ideas like
you've got a gift you've got a gift you
need to use it uh well so keep going
yeah go again go again
what doesn't kill you make you stronger
but you heard it before words of my
daughter I'm hurt but I'm working for
your 7-4 I'll be there when you call I
was there when you're born there when
you crawled unless you I thought
motivation when I'm quoted and my back's
on the wall go up in Florida can show on
my floors would you support if I gave up
on it all and said stop it and return to
withdrawal take up my cup for my Curtain
Call but hold up I gotta show up even
though I'm getting no love owners want
to know you know so much because they
own you I'm losing a bit of trust in my
corner one point twos four and fives and
beat tests keep me sober but these
voices keep telling me it's over the
Wellington closely I have a spell when
you're down you're supposed to I'm
handling the yelling from coaches while
I'm keeping kosher I'm not selling off
my soul to this culture I'm trying to
feel good but my thoughts say I'm stuck
is torture my sport is corrupt but I
bought all these Subs I've caught up
scoreboard as a plus court is Bluff but
they're forced into clutch so you gotta
get up
right oh wow way
one more
[Music]
no that's going to be a single gotta get
up but
that's not joking for a while that's all
about 40 going through hard times yeah I
could hear it right some some meaning
behind those lyrics it's so good love
that can't wait for that single gotta
get up all right gotta get up right
that's I think that would that would be
a good good song yeah to run out to yeah
we're on okay next one uh what's the key
to making so many tackles obviously you
made 70 in a game once that's
unbelievable
um more than I made in my whole career
I'd love to play rugby union bro
[Laughter]
like sometimes I hear the commentators
it always had a tough day he's made four
tackles
um
I think
in my mind all the time when I'm playing
I just want to look after my teammates
so if they need help on the tackle and
I'm there I'm gonna I'm gonna get in
there and help them
and like that's my mindset in defense
anyway and just help help how can I help
right yeah
it's yeah it's not
yeah
be a half back or be a center the job's
so much easier
don't be a fool you played a bit of
Santa right yeah when I was young when I
was young but bro don't play in the
forts don't
when you when you're making that many
tackles when you get to a tech what are
you just you're just gone you're just
starting to think about the next set on
day or
do you still have energy to add an
attack when you're when you're there
because that's that's a lot of tackles
there yeah no not really man like
after you put on Kick pressure on it and
then you hope your fullback doesn't drop
it and then you hope your window doesn't
drop it and then you hope your other
Winger doesn't drop so by tackle three
you should be on site
and then you're looking at one of your
forward saying
you're looking at one of the guys but
you take it and then like after
tackleford
and then as soon as that kick goes in
you're just thinking defense and then
you just get in the they call it the
washing machine gray and you're just in
there third men in the tackle back to a
third minute bro the grind yeah it goes
on and on and on yeah
over you don't want to be in there like
honestly any young kids don't play in
the Fords playing rugby league right
don't do that okay next question who's
the hardest NRL player that you played
with or against oh hardest thing hardest
player would probably be probably be
Thurston bro like oh yeah bro he would
just kick you to death like yeah you
could put on the best sit you could
defend the best
but then he gets your 40 he gets a 40 20
or like he puts a grab a kick in they're
building pressure you're defending your
line again
like and and then you'd get his
conversions from the sideline just like
bro just follow
um
yeah he'd be like any half of the good
kicking game
and just puts you on the pump like a
more crunk
like they'll just
it's not a fitness not even a physical
thing they're just kicking you to death
with their kicking yeah right it's just
taking your energy all the time crazy
hey what about toughest toughest will
probably be Simon Mandarin bro like oh
yeah he's a tough lad man
um
but he had done it all in the game he
was our captain at Warriors he had done
it all yeah and there was not one time I
heard him complain about anything
um right
that says a lot bro because there's a
lot of footy players that complain about
stuff yeah I'd imagine especially at the
Warriors two-way I'd imagine
yeah man like
any hard training you'll do it any hard
game you never want to come off and he
wouldn't complain about anything
um but as a testament to his character
now to me bro that's that's huge
um you know we've got some
pretty rough coaches we've got some
pretty rough trainers at the Warriors
sometimes and he never went behind in
the changing room saying no bro this is
[__] sorry he's a [__] or he never did
that once man and um something I really
admire after that would be Chris
Lawrence like bro his face got smashed
through no training like bad bro bad
um and then he was playing like five
months later right right tough man tough
tough crazy right that's cool about
mannering obviously he um he has a lot
of respect in that group he's what the
player of the year award he pretty much
won it every year he was there I think
it's called the mannering award now hey
so right why
and I just really said like he didn't
get us NRL like trophy as well bro he
puts so much on the line for their
Jersey
he works so hard as a captain as well
and for the kiwis
um yeah one of the New Zealand great
spray like I think he's he was pretty
underrated in Australia like but
back in the Warriors man he was the man
like he was definitely someone I looked
up to as soon as I got into first grade
yeah down to earth I think he was a
country boy as well
um came up from Nelson good Nelson
college man yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it came up from Nelson
like yeah humblewears like never
arrogant
um
yeah man he's someone there I supplied
up too for sure I love that okay next
one best coach you played under
probably Ivan yeah Ivan yeah because
obviously give me my fifth grade shot
and um we got a pretty good relationship
um and then at the Tigers so yeah
definitely Ireland someone asked was it
um the worst decision ever by the war is
letting go of Ivan yeah
yeah man that year his last year he got
got the reserves into the final we've
got the under 20s into the final and we
got first grade into the final 2011. and
then last year Pinterest the Brazil's on
the final down the 20s in the final and
the 16th of the final first grade in the
final and they all won yeah
um yeah that'd be one of the biggest
mistakes the Warriors had made for sure
got today could have been could have
been our year could have been our decade
yeah it just knows how to create a good
Pathways kind of thing
um and that Pinterest right that's just
a machine right now the next juniors are
coming through next Juniors coming
through
for the next decade definitely okay a
couple of angry Warriors fans have seen
in some questions but why do the
Warriors sack like
this is a harsh question but what is it
about the Warriors where they haven't
been able to
um
get a Premiership personally I think
it's the travel oh yeah because that's
the only thing that's consistent from
the Warriors start so the Warriors have
been consistently
not not as good as they could be
um but I noticed the difference bro
living in Paris compared to living in
Auckland
like playing parameters 20 minute drive
down the road yeah but an away game for
the Warriors bro that's a whole day of
their schedule dedicated to travel
but that's a whole day dedicated that's
their day off as a travel day you would
know all about that playing Super
um
and then the return date that's another
that's another one of your days off gone
um we're in penrith bro that was two
days off in a row you could just chill
at home and you felt so much better you
went fatigued
but
it has to be the travel bird lot
um compared to all the other teams
they've got to travel the most
um
and people think yeah it's only a
three-hour flight
but you got to think bro you got to get
there at least three hours earlier yeah
and then you that means you want to wake
up even an hour earlier than that so
you're waking up at like four in the
morning and then yeah your flight's only
three hours long but you've got to wait
a minute you're gonna check in buses and
all that robots yeah and then you have
your dinner and
that's the only thing that's been
consistent and the worries have been
inconsistent because they've had
different coaches they've had all the
different things but
that's my opinion uh the travel if they
can cut down the trouble
I think they'll be all right it's a
valid point and it would be cool I know
I think Sean Johnson's pushing for all
the Aussie teams to play their home
games against the Warriors back in
Auckland this year that would be cool
and then obviously if they happen to be
no excuse yeah good definitely no excuse
but that's the first time I heard there
bro yeah definitely
um but they should after all the
Warriors sacrificed for them for the
competition
yeah it's only right they should be cool
okay two more any tips for young players
in choosing an agent or representing
themselves
uh my opinion I think
there's a monopoly of agents that run
their NRL so there's probably five big
dogs of agents that have all the biggest
talent like your tedeschos or your you
know all the big names are probably
under five managers
so in my opinion go with one of those
five managers because they'll be able to
get you in a deal because they've got a
big dog at their club or you know and
like that's how they kind of work in
hindsight
you know one agent I know has half of
his players at one and one Club oh yeah
um and
surely do some deals that go on behind
the back door are you sign this bloke
and then I'll be able to bring you in
yeah if you don't sign them well he's
going to leave so you can sign him and
sign this kid as well like
there's a lot of stories as you get
older you hear these stories that go on
in the back doors when you're just like
it's pretty
that's pretty cool that's pretty bad but
if I was a young kid bro I'd be going to
Melbourne storm
straight away I wouldn't question I'll
be signing up for the storm whatever
um
and I'll be getting like one of the
bigger big agents um in the game and
stay well away from Ian miles
100 100
okay last question best piece of advice
you have for a water LED listener
oh man
um
best advice
uh bro life isn't fair
a lot of people think life is fair
well life should be fair
that's not the real world man like
as as soon as you leave school bro your
friends like the world's a rough place
like there's a lot of play people out
there that will take advantage of you
you know the the backstab y'all they're
trying to take your position they're
trying to get in good with the coach to
try and push you out of the club like
and that's only in the footy world like
I'm not I didn't even know what the
business World mode is like but I assume
it's the same
um
yeah life isn't fair because I used to
always think about Ian Mars and I was
like bro I don't understand why do I
deserve this
um and then with all the court stuff as
well I was just like bro like can I just
get my money and leave right
I haven't done anything wrong
um but out over a while I was just
confused
just don't think life's going to be fair
all the time because bro it's not
um and sometimes we go through school
we think everyone's you know a good life
which all good but then you get to the
real world and then Bang
the uh
sometimes you get a rude awakening
why you don't everyone very true and I
guess no one got more of a rude
awakening than yourself once you found
out miles had been still yeah yeah yeah
definitely crazy but mate how good what
a what a podcast what a what a journey
you've had
um really appreciate you coming on um
obviously I think so many kids will get
um heaps out of that um especially the
young ones
um who are probably looking for an agent
or young talented kids who unsure what
to do um there's some some really good
lessons there and um and and just on you
like what a career you've had and still
going
um all the best with what's next for you
flying airplanes or rapping in front of
80 000 people whatever it may be I wish
you all the best and appreciate you
coming on the podcast cheers James
thanks bro I really enjoyed it man thank
you for that it's cool mate you're a
lead appreciate it
[Music]
blood